Something I've been leaving off in all of the console commands I've
been running is an ending semicolon.
The inclusion or exclusion of a semicolon at the end of every line of
JavaScript has caused some disagreements in the JavaScript community.
In the language specification, it requires you, if you're trying to
be perfectly correct, to end every statement with a semicolon.
What's happened since JavaScript's come out, though,
is that people often forget semicolons, and the JavaScript interpreter, or
the browser, tries to make a best guess effort as what you meant.
You can get by without using semicolons, but it's best to be explicit.